hey guys I'm Ahmed Gina Roseanne's
kitchen table and I wanted to talk about
medicinal marijuana we've done a bunch
about marijuana and actually the laws
have been changing in the year and a
half that I've been doing this show laws
have changed a lot not only have a few
more states got in medicinal marijuana
but a couple states have gotten actual
recreational weed and nothing bad is
happening
oh hell isn't breaking loose it's like
if you like gays marry they keep
thinking all hell's gonna break loose
no the neighborhood gets nicer and it's
like the weed thing they're realizing
over getting tax revenue yeah so anyway
about two weeks ago I got my marijuana
card and you you kind of coached me
through it actually I was like a medical
marijuana guru yeah I went to the 4/20
doctors that's what they're called a
very professional straightforward yeah
Mary and I you know it's funny because I
had this feeling like I was going to
sort of like a real medical doctor I
assume that they are at some level or
something and I wanted to have I felt
like I needed like a reason you know and
I was like oh you know insomnia and
after I play basketball my legs hurt
baba the woman literally looked at me
like you want to get [ __ ] up but he
was like almost like I thought she was
almost like offended that I was coming
up with so many excuses yada yada yada
she writes you scribbles on a paper she
was like oh by the way and also take
magnesium and then yeah and then and
then that's it they hand you they
literally hand you a piece of paper and
then I walked about five blocks away and
I went into the dispensary and it's like
I don't even smoke that much weed that's
the thing I only smoke weed maybe once a
month yeah but I just thought it would
sort of be fun I don't know it's kind
anytime you don't want to do something
or you think that you're gonna be judged
for it you just say you're doing it for
a field report yeah I always when you
walked in there I bet you there was nary
a stethoscope there was no nothing yeah
there was no I didn't see a you know a
chart of the human body or no Grey's
Anatomy none of that
well anyway so I and which by the way
I'm sort of mocking it but you know what
I because I think marijuana should be
legal anyway I'm not really mocking it
because you shouldn't even have to go to
a doctor it's so silly and it seems like
the doctors that are you know
prescribing they obviously don't either
this
a loophole this is you know this is a
hurdle everyone's just trying to get
around so personally when I went because
I've to have that she's terrible
glaucoma yeah the doctor really did his
best job to like do some doctoring like
he was very serious and super hot
Spanish guy and you know asked me
questions about and and the more serious
he got the more serious I got and then
it was just this very like somber
dialogue about all my prot like my it
got weird is what I'm saying so did that
and then you just go back and you have
it reopened and the place I go to they
do a pretty good job of pretending to be
doctors yeah and then you go to the
dispensaries and at the dispensaries you
can get like edibles and you can get in
oil and it whacks a blob of bubble hash
anything you want yeah so by the way I
bought this you know like a vape pen and
some whatever to put in it and I
literally this is about three weeks ago
and or two weeks ago and I still haven't
even used it yeah so like the idea of
making this stuff legal that somehow
everyone's gonna become pot heads or you
know and it's also one of these things
where it's like you know the Republicans
they want tax revenue like they want
small government so that means you would
let people smoke weed in their homes if
you want small government and if you
want to raise money if you want to lower
taxes well you need to tax some other
things so why not tax wheat so it's like
one of these things it's so silly the
whole debate it's like yeah it's like
eating its tail and the two big debates
I think are well this is coming from the
tobacco companies big tobacco who
doesn't want this competition but then
it's like well aren't they just gonna
take over all the cannabis farms anyway
and just start Barbara yeah so I don't I
don't get in and it's not gonna be as
good cuz they're gonna you know if they
if it is like Starbucks were they gonna
do burn their weed beans so they get
more bang for their buck right so I
don't know what's really stopping people
I don't it seems so archaic it's yeah
it's like embarrassing that we're still
having this debate isn't it funny though
how it really has changed here in
California like it really is nothing I
think it's actually not nothing nobody
cares and by the way the reason why you
don't use your vape pen yeah is because
when you're high that vape pen looks
like a Rube Goldberg X it's like you
have to put a gigantic
it's trapped together and there is no
way you're gonna figure yeah there's all
you guys II gotta unscrew a light on it
anyway I'm really curious well I know
because most of our audience is pretty
much down poppets up not everybody
curious your thoughts should it be
medically available should it be
recreationally available are we just too
STONER what do they call the the
marijuana smoking I don't know let us
know in the comments right Network